from here all the
all before years some call them
neo-nazis others say they're one of
Ukraine's toughest fighting forces
the azov Battalion was formed in 2014
during the Russian annexation of Crimea
it began Life as a volunteer Force which
then became part of Ukraine's Armed
Forces with public links to far-right
groups
in 2016 the United Nations accused it of
violating International humanitarian law
in 2019 40 U.S Congress members
unsuccessfully tried to designate the
azov as a foreign terrorist organization
during this war they've become the main
fighting force in the besieged southern
city of mariopal we also have a
reputation we began by asking them if
there were a Neo-Nazi organization
sorry to say this but the image of us as
Neil Nazis was created by Russians in
2016. after azoba liberated marupo from
Russia our volunteer Fighters then
became part of the Ukrainian Army
there's a video on the National Guard of
Ukraine Twitter Crown which clearly
shows some of your Fighters greasing
bullets with pig facts with the message
dear Muslim Brothers in our country you
will not go to heaven go home please you
will not be allowed into heaven here you
encounter trouble go home please
that kind of thing makes you look like
neo-nazis the word
fact we have Muslims from Azerbaijan
fighting for us let me give you one
example in my unit we have a Muslim from
Azerbaijan he is fighting like us but
when people think of the as of Battalion
particularly internationally they do
think of neo-nazis you guys have an
image problem how are you dealing with
that
we have Russian propaganda a fifth
column that spread all over the world
it's not a surprise that they created
this Neo-Nazi image for us so now we are
speaking publicly come talk to us and
you see we are not the other Battalion
understands it has a Neo-Nazi image
problem but to change it will require
support from the rank and file many of
whom are suspected of having far-right
links Russian forces are just a few
kilometers from here but the azov
Battalion have another fight on their
hands if they want to change their image
from being a Neo-Nazi organization to
being a nationalist fighting Force
perhaps the bigger fight though is
within their members internally and how
that will go down Imran Khan Al Jazeera
Kiev